si je tweete ou hashtag sur la façon dont tu
n'as pas fait quelque chose de bien ou utilisé le
mauvais verbe ou alors je peux m'asseoir et me
sentir plutôt bien dans ma peau parce que
mec tu vois à quel point j'étais réveillé je t'ai appelé
[Musique]
donc
donc [Musique
]
étrangère [Musique]
ma [Musique
]
une
culture
[Musique]
est
donc [
Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
so
[Music]
[Music] l'
une de leurs armes politiques est d'annuler la
culture chassant les gens de leur travail
en faisant honte aux dissidents et en exigeant une soumission totale
de quiconque n'est pas d'accord c'est la
définition même
du totalitarisme et c'est complètement
étranger à notre culture et à nos valeurs
et ça n'a absolument pas sa place aux
États-Unis
d'Amérique
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous